um first
to introduce Eric
PhD students in the history of
architecture hi story of architecture at
Boston University in 2010 she received
her MA in art history from the
University of Illinois at Chicago where
she began focusing on design cultures of
the 1940s her dissertation tomorrow on
display American and British housing
exhibitions 1942 1955 investigates how
exhibition curators visualized
materialized and conquer tized abstract
ideas about town planning dwellings and
home furnishings for approval and
consumption by a skeptical but curious
lay public in March of this year the
paul mellon center for studies in
British Heart awarded her a junior
fellowship and to continue research on
this topic and she currently teaches
courses in the history of interior
architecture and design at Boston
Architectural college and at Boston
University so I will have a welcome
Aaron mckellar thanks everybody it's so
nice to see although of course I can't
see you because it's dark so many of you
here um for what promises to be a very
exciting weekend of talks ok writing for
the observer in 1944 Alison settle
praised the London showing of American
housing in war and peace for tackling
the problem of the post-war dwelling
here she noted that American architects
and designers were quote concentrating
on dwellings which are homes they
realized that the fighting men on their
return having had enough of communal
life in the services will value privacy
above all else the Americans as we must
are fighting the battle for adequate
house living space that settled defined
dwellings as homes is significant while
dwelling refers specifically to shelter
home implies additional cultural value
moreover she drew a distinction between
communal living and homes that provided
for a nuclear family in its display I'm
american housing and Warren peece made
it clear to visitors that the ideal
post-war dwelling was intended for a
family unit these ideas reflected a
belief widespread through both the US
and Britain that family life formed the
basis of a happy existence and which saw
the home as the first priority in
reconstruction because family life was
the most important aspect of life and
the cultural value that settle
acknowledged was also a political and
patriotic one the poster for American
war and peace which you can see on the
screen exemplifies this political value
by depicting the blueprints for a house
with the American flag stripes flashing
on the blueprints verso making the
visual claim that America literally
supported the act of building the family
home and we can look at american housing
and Warren peece as the culmination of
wartime research into ideal forms of
post-war reconstruction as the Second
World War initiated defense projects
destroyed cities from above prompted
material shortages and demanded
participation from average citizens
housing advocates on both sides of the
Atlantic seized an opportunity to
rethink dwellings on a mass scale the
war thus enabled architects to
experiment with improving family life
for the post-war years in Britain one
organization that engaged these
questions was the reconstruction
committee of the Royal Institute of
British Architects which formed in March
1941 to respond to the 3 million homes
throughout Britain that had been damaged
or destroyed by aerial bombings the
committee promoted its ideas in two
major exhibitions in 1943 the first of
these exhibitions rebuilding Britain
visualized ideas about housing outlined
in the Beveridge report in 1944 american
housing in war and peace which was
co-sponsored by the US Office of War
Information and organized by the Museum
of Modern Art in New York before going
on display in London contended that
Britain could learn from America how to
plan large-scale housing
developments and build them with speed
and economy centering on the family home
as the embodiment of the ways of life
that both nations sought to defend
rebuilding britain and american housing
and Warren peece displayed architect
design proposals for planned
neighborhoods and modern dwellings these
tools of persuasion simultaneously
promoted modern architectural ideas
tried to carve a place for the architect
in post-war Britain and demonstrated to
wartime audiences the cultural value of
the family home in the process these
displays anticipated an improved
post-war future reassuring visitors that
the conflicts end would bring about a
better world so in this talk which I
broken up roughly into three parts I'll
first outline the professional climate
that made print planning a priority in
wartime Britain next I'll connect the
wartime goals of the revo reconstruction
committee to this climate and then walk
you through the two exhibitions and then
finally I'll briefly evaluate the
efficacy of their modes of display
starting in the early days of the war
architects anticipated and predicted the
post-war world through a process of
planning that extended from the
individual dwelling to its place within
the region as various planning
historians have noted many British
architectural planning proponents saw
the blitzes damage much of which had
wiped out entire slum areas as an
opportunity or chance to enact
comprehensive town plans beginning to
wreak by planning to reconstruct these
destroyed areas architects and other
professionals sought to expand their
roles in the town planning process by
seizing this opportunity these
individuals understood that the total
nature of the war had created a social
climate that was hospitable to such
change moreover British Architects and
housing experts saw this moment as a
chance to modernize Britain's outdated
housing especially advocating for their
role in this process these professionals
almost immediately commenced planning
for Britain's reconstruction publicizing
their work as they
went in january nineteen forty one for
example the popular picture post
magazine special published a special
issue entitled a plan for britain this
issue looked back to nineteen eighteen
when the nation had emerged from the
first world war with no comprehensive
plan and insisted we can be better
prepared but we can only be better
prepared if we think now this process of
planning to connected to allied wartime
goals quoting from the same issue our
plan for a new britain is not something
outside of the war or something after
the war it is indeed our most positive
war aim the new britain is the country
we are fighting for and the kind of land
we want the kind of life we think the
good life will exercise an immense
attraction over the oppressed peoples of
Europe and the friendly peoples of
America end quote this new better
Britain it hinged on improving family
life as the magazine's cover suggests by
picturing children as the future of the
nation here in features by future
members of the reader reconstruction
committee maxwell fry and elizabeth
dendi outlined how british architects
might plan the nation's built landscape
and homes to provide pleasant and
comfortable places in which to reside
and so here on the screen we see a sort
of old new proposal we're on the on your
right or my right your left we have the
city as it is presently um and then on
your right we see the city as it could
be and at the heart of it right up here
we have small houses in their own
gardens which would provide clean and
healthy family living and this occupies
as you can see a very prominent location
within what is frys proposal for a plan
city meanwhile den be asserted that
architects must plan houses for the
needs of families particularly
housewives she offered a proposal for a
convenient
in hygienic kitchen that followed modern
planning principles integrated modern
technologies and made use of easy to
clean modern materials such as linoleum
in an article published by the
architects journal in December 1941
Kenneth Lindsay late parliamentary
secretary to the Board of Education
built upon these foundations insisting
that British reconstruction was to be a
collaborative effort in so doing he
argued British reconstruction would
provide a genuinely democratic example
to the quote stunted mechanized German
government and in casting reconstruction
as a democratic effort of extension of
the war effort Lindsay linked
architecture with Britain's social life
one that was implicitly at odds with
that of a totalitarian regime here he
argued that the home comprised the first
priority in the process of
reconstruction followed by community
centres and civic buildings because in
his words family life matters most by
extension Lindsay acknowledged that
instilling in children British values
chiefly those associated with democracy
would first happen at home before
extending to the larger community
further because fighting the war implied
protecting cultural values the family
home stood at the center of this
struggle is the place in which these
values were born nurtured and
perpetuated amid this climate the RIBA
reconstruction committee engaged
architects with questions of town
planning transportation industry housing
finance organization and administration
all as they related to post-war building
collectively the organization's members
adopted the belief that policy must
precede planning planning must precede
execution and all of the resources of
the building industry must be involved
the family home occupied a central
position within the reconstructions
could commit the reconstruction
committee's mission and from the
committee's formation in nineteen in
March 1941 a special housing group
consider the planning fittings and
furnishings of both urban and rural
housing recommending appropriate
standards for each component the
reconstruction committee believed that a
large exhibition would best visualize
its fuse on the briton that was possible
in the future rebuilding Britain which
went on display at London's National
Gallery on February twenty-fifth
nineteen forty-three educated British
citizens about town planning by
articulating its significance throughout
history connecting these ideas directly
to social policies and proposals that
had developed during the Warriors and
positing that planned cities would build
a better Britain moreover the
reconstruction committees solicited the
public's participation in doing so as
part of the democratic process just as
reconstruction should be a collaborative
effort the committee treated rebuilding
Britain as collaboration no individual
members name appeared on any of the
exhibition's materials including its
text and catalogue the exhibition's
organisers aim to convince visitors how
British citizens might transform the
nation in the postwar years visitors to
the National Gallery met an opening
scene that depicted destruction and
alluded to wartime opportunity by
displaying a large photograph of st.
Paul's Cathedral with an expansive blitz
London behind it and we don't have this
because they're his no picture of it the
overall design of the exhibition space
was aimed aimed to render legible the
material of rebuilding Britain it's
exhibition coordinators draped the
gallery walls to a height of 8 feet with
dark blue grey fabric which formed the
backdrop to a series of plywood screens
supported by white tubular metal frames
distinctively colored materials covered
each of the plywood screens each color
emphasizing the exhibition's different
stages British architectural inheritance
historic town planning modern town
planning modern construction and so on
the metal frames that supported each
screen also held reflectors that
directed light onto the M
on display mainly as you can see here
black and white photographs to offer
visitors a palpable sense of what this
new britain might look like a small
number of models also accompany the
exhibition imagery in the midst of war
the interdepartmental committee on
social insurance and allied services
chaired by leading british economist
william beveridge identified an
opportunity to enact the comprehensive
social change that would bring about
this new britain in december 1942
beverage published his report on social
insurance and allied services this
document identified five giant evils
standing in the way of reconstruction
want disease ignorance squalor and
idleness because rebuilding britain
attempted to visualize some of beverages
ideas by focusing on the built
environment the reconstruction committee
invited him to open the gallery by the
exhibition by explicitly tying the
exhibition's content to the content of
his report his speech which was
broadcast on the radio declared war on
squalor of course one of his giant evils
to beverage squalor meant that many
British people were residing in houses
that lacked access to green space most
of these houses were small poorly
equipped difficult to keep clean an
inconvenient to workplaces beverage
asserted that a planned reconstruction
would enable quote all citizens to live
in an environment that is healthy clean
and pleasing to the senses clear of
offence to sight hearing and small smell
giving easy access to work and
recreation alike end quote the solution
he contended depending on cooperation
between Britain's elected officials and
its citizens to ensure planned use of
land and intelligent use of transport
with the guidance of architects as
experts the underlying goal of
rebuilding Britain was to rally the
British public to demand this
professionally planned reconstruction
although the exhibition's stated goal
emphasizes the act of rebuilding and
thus underscored new building planning
also implied preserving the best parts
of Britain's built
landscape while protecting against
unmitigated development in the
exhibitions first gallery visitors
encountered encountered a sequence that
historically trace the nation's
inheritance of good building and natural
scenery exemplified in built form by
buildings such as vas Royal Crescent
pictured here the purpose of such images
was to contrast 19th century industrial
development and the so-called evils that
this unregulated development had brought
to the nation by extension the
exhibition's organizers sought to meet
clear that long-term planning was
essential for Britain's future
development planning for future
exhibition contended was not at all at
odds with a traditional British life but
rather a return to a better way of
living while the exhibition screens no
longer exist and few photographs remain
to illustrate the specific proposals
that rebuilding Britain conveyed about
housing its many accompany accompanying
publications revealed a significant role
that housing played within the show as a
whole and much of this centered on rapid
construction within a plan framework for
example a feature within the
architectural review insisted that
post-war housing needs would be on a
gigantic scale because labor would be at
a premium the architectural review
advocated for rapid economical
construction to ensure the nation's
health and well-being the exhibition
presented audiences with the idea that
this new construction would fit within
carefully crafted Civic units which
would form the social structure of the
city without offering specific proposals
for reconstruction rebuilding Britain
showed visitor viewers what these units
the district unit the borough unit the
neighbourhood unit and the residential
unit all of which are pictured on the
top of this magazine page might look
like and diagrammed how they fit
together the exhibition screen
explaining the concept of a residential
unit pictured here explained that 200
families would form an ideal residential
unit thus at the heart of it all the
family comprised the basis for the whole
structure however because planning
concerns more than one family the
exhibition and its accompanying
materials demonstrated to visitors how
families fit into this greater scheme as
part of a larger totality and the end of
the exhibition prompted visitors to
demand a planned reconstruction as
members of a democratic citizenry on the
heels of rebuilding Britain's success
the RIBA reconstruction committee
decided to stage in exhibitions focus
solely on housing a question that
rebuilding Britain had only start begun
to explore because American architects
have gained experience building in
quantity through large-scale
governmental programs the RIBA turned to
the US OWI for assistance the OWI
commissioned moment with the task of
producing a display that focused on mass
production and housing particularly
during wartime and anticipated some of
the problems Britain might face when the
war ended american housing and Warren
peace which ran from July 19th through
August twenty-eighth 1944 centered on
prefabrication and standard building as
solutions to Britain's housing crisis by
allowing architects to design plans the
builders could execute on a mass scale
as rebuilding Britain had done American
hat worn housing in Warren peece
displayed photographs diagrams and text
on freestanding flat wood panels these
likewise were color coded navy blue
white yellow and light blue according to
their sections which emphasized new
materials and methods of construction
modern site planning and good social
organization by illustrating built
examples conceived and designed by Mary
cook with Katherine Bauer as consultant
and British graphic designer fhk Henry
on as the london-based estate display
designer american housing in Warren
peece outlined some of the most
innovative American strategies for
emergency and local
housing this was a subject on which both
cook and Bauer had amassed considerable
expertise cook worked for american
housing authorities in washington DC
after returning from britain in 1935
where she had worked for the
architectural firm tekton meanwhile
bauer was vice president of the
California Housing and Planning
Association and had been a leader in the
movement toward social housing in the
United States after the publication of
her landmark book modern housing in 1934
in 1942 observing American wartime
building efforts Bauer proclaimed that
the war was providing quote vast
laboratory experience with experimental
building methods and prefabrication with
large-scale community planning with
rental management and upkeep and with
streamlined production processes all of
which Bauer believed would revitalize
the building industry in the post-war
era unsurprisingly since they both
engaged actively with social housing in
the US cook and Bauer presented housing
as a social problem and outline how
American policy and the war emergency
had begun to alleviate American living
conditions many of the exhibition's
proposals clearly engaged with their
ideas the exhibition's opening screen
pictured here and I apologize for the
quality depicts a man woman and a baby a
nuclear family overlaid upon an aerial
view of a massive wartime housing
development in San Diego introductory
text on the image reads US housing and
Warren peece this imagery would have
established for visitors an unmistakable
connection between the dwelling here
relatively anonymous mass housing and
the family by extension this imagery
served to personalize mass housing by
allowing visitors to see themselves in
the position of the family cook and
Bauer endeavored to give families agency
throughout the exhibition as well in
terms of social planning they maintained
that community facilities must be
provided so that projects could function
as neighborhood units and tenants could
participate in active cooperation with
the organization
of their housing for physical planning
the exhibition contended that long rows
of houses on a flat site were
unattractive intended to become rundown
that landscape areas should be designed
carefully that small projects were
easier to manage than large ones that
walk up should be no larger than three
storeys in height and that interior
standards must be kept flexible good
examples included among others housing
rather close to where we are today in
Windsor Locks Connecticut designed by
Hugh Stubbins here staggered site plans
afforded family's privacy and so you can
see here that there's these triangular
formations and these formations where
you're not looking directly into your
neighbor's windows um Interior standards
like wives were small but kept flexible
and provided residents with modern
kitchen bathroom and heating facilities
by focusing on these questions cook and
Bauer contended that Britain could learn
from America's wartime experience the
Reba's exhibition announcement expressed
an interest in demonstrating how
American experience was relevant to
britain's claiming her varied
geographical and social conditions meant
that the US had experienced many of the
housing problems we have met with here
in Britain the RIBA maintained that many
of the solutions and experienced
experiments that American architects had
produced during the Depression and in
the war time were relevant to Britain's
anticipated need to provide temporary
housing while permanent dwellings were
being constructed the RIBA along with
various architectural publications
framed the examples of built work shown
in the exhibition as stemming from
British origins by stating that many of
much of American mass housing was
inspired by earlier British legislation
and planning so finally today I'd like
to address both exhibitions portability
which was essential for both of them to
function effectively as persuasive tools
this portability as we'll see
contained two key layers first both
exhibitions designers conceived their
wood panel displays screens with
portability in mind because the initial
showings at the National Gallery and at
the Reba's headquarters both in London
would have attracted limited British
audiences both exhibitions visited a
number of other locations as well in a
case of rebuilding Britain a small
committee translated the National
Gallery's display on 23 smaller versions
for the Council of the encouragement of
music in the arts to circulate from 1943
through 1946 rebuilding Britain traveled
to more than 40 cities and towns
throughout England Scotland and Wales
appearing at local museums but also
schools community centers libraries and
municipal buildings this variety
demonstrates the large nationwide
interest in the exhibition and reveals
that local municipalities wish to engage
the question of reconstruction in some
of these circulating showings rebuilding
Britain's broad proposals appears
alongside specific local plans for
reconstruction american housing and
Warren peece meanwhile travelled
throughout England and Scotland from
1944 through 1946 where it to appeared
at a range of local galleries schools
and libraries the second layer of
portability pertains to the various
publications that reprinted the content
of both exhibitions as rationing meant
that paper wasn't scarce supply
throughout the war these publications
attest to the events significance and
demonstrate that organisers believed it
was truly important to make these
messages known to books accompanied
rebuilding Britain first a catalogue
here's the catalogue that officially
complimented the exhibition and then
later and our contextual review special
issue which read was republished as a
pocket guide and the intention of this
pocket guide was to quote smooth the
path of visitors because the panel's
contained relatively little text and
people were concerned that they would
that average people would actually not
understand the exhibition's
material in 1944 the architectural
review also printed a similar special
issue that fully recapped american
housing and war in peace while the
exhibition was still circulating in 1946
penguin published homes by the million a
book that while not officially
affiliated with the exhibition drew
significantly from its content imagery
and examples to convey ideas about mass
housing more effectively to a wide
audience the books introductory pages
even repeated the overlaid imagery that
had appeared on the first screen of
american housing and Warren peece thus
creating a lasting connection between
mass housing and the family here
recontextualized as facing a new
post-war era this portability ranging
from circulating iterations of both
exhibitions to the publications that
accompanied them ensured the average
British citizens throughout England
Scotland and Wales could access these
important messages in so doing
rebuilding Britain and american housing
and Warren peece not only set out to
convince audiences that planning was
necessary and to create demand for the
architectural professions role in the
nation's impending reconstruction but
also to reinforce the significance of
the family home both during Warren peece
reassuring a war-weary British citizenry
that a reward lay in sight thank
you